hey reject nation I'm Greg and I'm John
and I'm Lauren yeah
I want my lord from the Iowa mile or in
YouTube channel go follow her there some
hilarious videos on there in a lot of
live stream goron and I watched a video
from the movie if it was if but would
Shrek I watch the TV spot number one for
the movie it already that's already up
on the tube there's a TV spot number two
oh boy I'm just going to show you guys
TV spot number one right now for you
guys
okay thank you thanks man and then we'll
watch number two I'm not going to react
to this one yeah so serious ah there's
no need to show any emotion
[Music]
the CDs he does look horrifying that
Pennywise so let's move on to number two
this is the one I haven't seen it's
called a wonderful day but before we
move on I just wanted to tell you guys
that that is how I greet every woman in
the morning after I'm done maybe one of
them to see balloon so a lot of friends
look everywhere it happens it's all
connected by the sewers September is
that was that was freaky yeah kill them
all that's what my mom would have all
the children sing at my birthday party
yeah oh yeah right day but I liked about
that trailer all the other trailers are
very terrifying and creepy we not idea
this one was like capitalizing on the
hope of these children you know banding
together and having to take down it
we're gonna figure this out let's figure
this out because people really love that
kind of thing from kids in these 80s
movies yeah supervised children digging
dangerous and armed with nothing but
bikes backpacks and ever sticks around I
thought it was scary I liked the first
trailer in Spanish yeah in Spanish yeah
it's creepier in Spanish it is a little
creepier just the subtitle makes it
scarier that jump-scare like I almost
grabbed you guys like it's just like ya
know
they're doing a great job getting a day
for John and I have that happen I'm so
this guy and I haven't even hugged a
woman college again like eight months
six to eight business day sixty-eight
businessman yeah it started last weekend
we yeah well I hugged my mom last
weekend and she is a woman it doesn't
you know I mean but you know like the
act to happen so you know I don't count
it but you know the technicality well
subscribe that's the button it does
plenty things for example you don't get
notified when it videos out you got to
click that notification bell yeah which
still might not really increase your
odds of finding it also check out John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
I want my Lauren on the channel YouTube
if you don't do any of the things I
instructed prior you must just do at
least one and that is follow Lauren
French s all oh yes she's pretty yes
she's a hard worker all those things but
more importantly she has a youtube where
are you doing is funny that would have
given you what you wanted I know that's
how your real living Greg giving them
not what they want yeah but what they
need exactly which is the desire to
watch yeah
mark hiding - oh yeah or them visit it's
been a few days a business days gonna
give us a brain